yeah with inbound belly and I think New
York you know really I have traveled a
lot I mean there are some pretty grim
things that you have to eat but they're
all edible if you eat them quickly but
in New York and the kind of restaurants
that I go to I mean it's my duty to
consume everything on my plate and it's
not it's not it's not that hard to do I
mean and I don't have certain things
like chicken liver that I don't like or
tribe or chickens feed in fact I like
all those things so I'm perfectly happy
you know with a big bowl of students
kidneys probably I just I just read an
article about it recently in the last
year to year a few months I I was in
Japan and Japan is a I mean it's
probably the best eating not eating
Tokyo itself like New York it's probably
the best eating town and in the world
now your mission I just did a guide
there and I think the total stars they
gave out in New York and London were
something likes between 70 and 80 stars
to all the fancy restaurants in Tokyo
that gave out 160 hundred seventy stars
to all the various restaurants there
anyway so the Japanese cooking this very
high level all different kinds of food
Japanese Italian Brazilian French but
they also cook a lot of really bizarre
strange things you go to these beautiful
department stores in the basement say
these beautiful food holes which make
the fancy boutique food food places in
New York look like McDonald's not quite
like McDonald's but they're you know on
that level and they are they're selling
next to these beautiful shiny French
pastries they're selling
platters of grilled eel gizzards which
tastes like you know fish liver that's
been soaked in butane and during the
course of that trip I had I had a I had
those those eel gizzards and I also had
a grilled chicken ovaries which is you
know yakitori which is that it's grilled
on a stick Oh different kinds of meat
the ovaries are they grill it and it's
basically these sort of gizzards which
are which are sort of squeezed on the
stick and at the end of it is the ovary
which looks like a bobbing egg yolk and
it actually tastes quite good but it
looks so freaky when it's bobbling
around and then you eat it the yolk
burst in your mouth and it's the innards
of a chicken so that was sort of grisly
and i also had do it on that trip i ate
fugu which is the Blowfish which is the
poisonous Blowfish which is a great
delicacy in Japan and I've just written
a story about this and the the top PS to
resist dolls delicacy of fugu is the
engorged sperm sack of the male fish and
they'll serve that grilled little pieces
like summer marshmallows and there's
really no taste to it but you bite it
again it's on a stick and they little
burnt white things not burnt but but
lightly grilled and then you bite it in
that the sort of hot fish meal will sort
of flood and around in your mouth and
its really it's sort of disgusting but I
didn't
member